Imagine you’re in the muddy trenches on
the western front during World War One.
You’re wet and shivering and can’t get warm.
Your days are marked by sleeplessness, fear,
and cigarettes that are too soggy to light.
Death is all around you.
On the other side across from no
man’s land are enemy soldiers.
With advancements in technology
- your comrades are mowed down
by killing machines in numbers beyond imagination.
But you have no time to mourn…just
fight…lest you suffer the same fate.
But then...amid unrelenting violence…the
bloodshed and brutality suddenly…stop.
You put your weapons down – cross the enemy lines,
shake hands, and pose for photos with your
foe…even play a game of soccer or football!
To this day, it remains one of the
STRANGEST moments in the history of war.
On Christmas Eve, 1914, Captain Arthur
O’Sullivan of the British Army’s Royal
Irish Rifles was stationed in France
on the northern border with Belgium.
The guns were silent, and
he heard a German voice say:
“Do not shoot after 12 o’clock
and we will not do so either”
“If you English come out and
talk to us, we won’t fire.”
Was it a trick? There was only one way to know
for sure. An Irishman dared to venture out to no
man’s land - the area between the opposing
armies’ trenches - and was not shot at.
When he reached the German side, an
enemy soldier gave him a cigarette.
When he returned safely,
his comrades clambered out of the trench and went
to meet the Germans halfway across no man’s land.
Their superiors would be forgiven
for reacting with more caution.
Brigade headquarters cabled back warning: “It is
thought possible that enemy may be contemplating
an attack during Xmas or New Year. Special
vigilance will be maintained during this period.”
At 8:30 pm that night, Captain
O’Sullivan’s commanding officer,
Colonel George Laurie, reported to headquarters:
“Germans have illuminated their trenches,
are singing songs and wishing us a Happy
Xmas. Compliments are being exchanged but am
nevertheless taking all military precautions.”
Colonel Laurie described the Germans as
“fine men, clean and well clothed. They gave
us a cap and helmet badge and a box of cigars.
One of them states the war would be over in
three weeks as they had defeated Russia!”
Despite thinking the war would be over soon,
World War I would actually last four years,
leaving 10 million soldiers dead
and about as many civilians.
Yet, for a fleeting moment, good appeared to
triumph over evil. Instead of exchanging bullets,
sworn enemies exchanged handshakes.
Colonel Laurie later recalled:
“You have no idea how pleasant
everything seems with no rifle
bullets or shells flying about.”
Further down the line, a German officer
who was a tenor in the Berlin Opera
began singing “Silent Night”
in both German and English,
encouraging his comrades whose voices
flowed over to the British trenches.
The contrast between the Christmas carol’s message
of peace and the violence of war was striking.
The same spirit of camaraderie sprung
up in various sectors along the front
which weaved more than 400 miles
through France and Belgium.
Soldiers later wrote to their loved ones
expressing their disbelief over what had occurred.
British soldier Private Frederick Heath described
in his letter home that he heard the Germans say:
‘Come out, English soldier; come out here to us.’
For some little time we were cautious, and did not
even answer. Officers, fearing treachery, ordered
the men to be silent. But up and down our line one
heard the men answering that Christmas greeting
from the enemy. How could we resist wishing each
other a Merry Christmas, even though we might be
at each other’s throats immediately afterwards?
So we kept up a running conversation with
the Germans, all the while our hands ready
on our rifles. Blood and peace, enmity
and fraternity—war’s most amazing paradox.
The night wore on to dawn—a night made easier
by songs from the German trenches, the pipings
of piccolos and from our broad lines laughter
and Christmas carols. Not a shot was fired.
The front page of the Illustrated London News
described a German soldier approaching the British
lines with a small tree, as a sign of a truce.
Very cautiously, Allied and German soldiers
climbed out of their trenches and crossed no
man's land, where they shared drinks with their
enemies, as depicted in the film Joyeux Noël.
I don’t think anyone would criticize us for
laying down our rifles on Christmas Eve.
Don’t worry, it is just for tonight.
The guns remained silent on Christmas day.
Although there were accounts of fighting in some
sectors, the Imperial War Museums believes the
truce extended along at least two-thirds of the
British-held trench line in southern Belgium.
“The most detailed estimate, made by Malcolm
Brown of Britain’s Imperial War Museums,
is that the truce extended along
at least two-thirds of British-held
trench line that scarred southern Belgium.”
German and British soldiers can be seen
standing together in photographs taken
on personal cameras that the soldiers
brought into the trenches with them.
It was not easy for them to communicate, however,
what they DID have in common
was an interest in sports.
A British private described “at least a couple
hundred” soldiers kicking around a football.
This was one of several impromptu soccer
matches played in no man’s land.
Amongst the joy, there was sadness as
both sides also used this opportunity
to recover the bodies of their fallen
comrades and give them a decent burial
which they couldn’t do in the heat of battle.
Headlines around the world spread
the news of the Christmas truce
which must have seemed incredulous to
the public. Especially since British
government propaganda portrayed German
soldiers as ruthless, barbaric monsters.
And yet enemies were here mingling together.
A German Lieutenant recalled: “How
marvelously wonderful, yet how strange it was.
The English officers felt the same way about
it. Thus Christmas, the celebration of Love,
managed to bring mortal enemies
together as friends for a time.”
“For a time” is right.
Because the next day, they went
back to shooting each other.
Strict orders came down from the pike, and
they had to retreat back to their trenches.
This would be the only widespread Christmas truce
during the course of the entire four-year war.
High Commands on both sides prohibited
fraternizing with the enemy.
And the war became increasingly bitter
after the introduction of poison gas
the following year and the number
of casualties began to pile up.
(battles of Somme and Verdun very ugly,
also, poison gas was introduced in 1915)
The Christmas truce of 1914 was indeed an
anomaly, so hard to believe that over time,
some people even doubted that it really happened,
despite all the evidence to the contrary.
British machine gunner Bruce Bairnsfather,
who later became a prominent cartoonist,
depicted the truce in his work. In this cartoon,
he shows himself taking a fancy to the buttons
of the German officer. They agreed to do a swap.
In his memoirs, Bairnsfather
described the incredulity of it all.
“Here they were—the actual, practical
soldiers of the German army.
There was not an atom of hate on either side.”
Even in the darkest hour, good
triumphed over evil, if just for a day.
They had gotten to know the
enemy. And realized they were more alike
than the propaganda of the day would suggest.
And realized they were more
alike than they thought.
Making these videos takes up a lot of my time.
So I like to make sure the rest of
my day is as hassle-free as possible.
And that’s down to the wallet that I use.
So this is the wallet that I used to use.
And this is the wallet I
currently own – an Ekster wallet.
It’s clearly a lot more sleek and simpler.
I actually started using an Ekster wallet
before the company approached me to see if
I was interested in getting them
to sponsor some of my videos.
And I said of course, yes.
I absolutely love Ekster wallets.
They’re super simple to use.
All you have to do is press this button and
then you get access to all of your cards.
I especially love this model in particular
because there’s a spot to put my AirTag
which is very convenient as I don’t have
to spend time looking for the wallet in
my house, I know where it is at all times.
There are so many models to choose from.
You can check them out on their website.
Ekster also sent me this really cool
wallet. This is made of carbon fiber wallet.
It’s super sleak and very minimalistic
and I absolutely love the design.
To go along with it, you can also
get yourself a smart tracking card.
Ekster’s runs on solar power. All it needs is
three hours in the sun and it lasts two months.
If you’d like to try out an Ekster wallet, you
can get 20% off if you use my custom link. That’s
https://shop.ekster.com/newsthink - again, the
link is in my description or pinned comment.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom